let's bring in Kirk Herbstreit from the
mothership and Herbie joins us now
Herbie a great job you and Chris last
night and congratulations throughout the
Bulls season what were your expectations
when that game started what did you
think was going to happen you know I
thought there was so much talk leading
up to the game that the physical and low
scoring and you know just just about the
running games that the familiarity with
with the two coaches mmm the staffs on
both sides I thought it would be more
about the quarterback play I thought
Jake Fromm would be given opportunities
because he's so tough to run the ball
against Bama so I thought he would be he
did have chances to make plays I wonder
about Jalen Hurd's a guy that just has
not progressed as a passer seeing
coverage making decisions working
progressions with brian de bal who came
over from the patriots he just hasn't
stepped up in that in that fashion so i
knew he could run but i didn't think you
could throw consistently so I thought
Georgia kids a better quarterback play
probably had a little bit of an
advantage coming into the game but I I
thought the quarterbacks would be to
eventually be the difference in the game
when did you get word that there was
going to be a quarterback game change in
have fun
well it's funny we met with was with
Nick two days a day or two before the
game and there's always that when you do
an Alabama game there's always that are
they gonna put to it in the game feel
it's been going on since their he came
in with spring of last year and threw
for over 300 yards their fan base went
oh my gosh this guy can throw and we got
to play him and yet Jalen Hurst got him
to the national championship as a
freshman so it's kind of been
malingering he just hasn't ever been
given an opportunity to have meaningful
snaps so when you sit down to call the
national championship and coach and I
and Chris we all have a really pretty
candid relationship and I said you know
midway through it I said I coach 13 you
know is this is there a chance is there
a series I mean any kind of crossed his
arms and got a little uncomfortable and
he said you know you know there's a
chance and I said is it is a gut feel is
it is it premeditated and he says
probably a little more
meditating and then I kept pushing which
he doesn't like and I said you know I
said what if he goes in and he goes
eight plays 80 yards touchdown and then
he got kind of mad at me he's like
listen I get enough going on I know I
don't I don't have time for I don't have
time for hypotheticals and it's because
this scale in Hertz 25 and two he could
see the two straight national
championships he put into a what if he
goes in and does really well and there's
a there's a switch that was my point and
so anyway that was the backdrop so then
we get into the game and clearly bamas
offenses are doing a lot they're very
one-dimensional to running the ball they
could get the tailbacks going Alabama
was George's loaded up against a run so
when Tom Rinaldi interviewed him at
going off at halftime if you listen very
closely to what Nick said based on our
meeting the day before and then what he
said to Tom Rinaldi when they threw it
back up to us before he went to halftime
with Reese I said would not be surprised
if two of got an opportunity to maybe
Trabant paratus park in the second half
that's that's all I said it was more of
speculation and inside info and sure
enough we kept cameras on him when he
came out after after halftime and right
away you could tell that he got his
helmet on and guys were coming over
high-fiving him and it was like oh hey
here we go kids gonna get a shot and
just based on watching him in practice
we've been around Alabama we've all
known what he was capable of doing in
practice what did he do it on that stage
in that game against the speed of that
defense that was the history and of
course he ended up delivering yeah I
don't know if I'm making too much of it
but to me to have a coach who makes that
call at halftime down 13 nothing
national title game with a starter who's
the former offensive player of the year
in the SEC who's twenty five and two and
you make that call and you make that
call because you know that that could
have reverberations into the second half
obviously but next season as well that
now we're talking about Jalen Hertz
maybe transferring and then this kid
might be one of the frontrunners for the
Heisman I mean it it's unbelievable
really to make that call Dan I don't
think we can make a big enough deal
about it because it
it gave Alabama national championship
and in it and it's as you said the risk
and you're 25 and - this guy's got you
to two straight national championships
and to be you know maybe only Nick Saban
makes that call because of the
confidence that he has and who he is but
it's unprecedented I've never seen
anything like that that kid again he
looks great last night he's gonna only
played mop-up duty has it taken think
about that a meaningful snap and coach
says you know what nobody has done it
against our own defense
this defense plays very similar defense
that we play we need a spark and Brian
dable that the offensive coordinator
who's done a great job of I call it kind
of complimentary football as a play
caller is typically very conservative
but going into the game jaylen hurts
only one interception very cautious with
him he in my opinion he had one arm tied
behind his back as a play caller because
they just don't have ability to throw
the ball put two in and it was almost
like and Brian people love jaylen hurts
it's not that it's all of a sudden and
open up this side of the play sheet and
you could just feel I'm sure watching
and we could feel him up in the booth
different energy different pace
all of a sudden they start to get some
tempo going to scramble on third and
seven where he showed some toughness and
so grit to pick it up gave him a little
bit of momentum they score touchdown the
defense kind of feeds off of the energy
coming from - and you seen in the pro
game a lot what a diagram that not only
affecting the offense but the energy in
the stadium the defense starts to play
with a little bit of an attitude you
really sparked that team to allow them
to come back tie the game and ended up
winning at her overtime yeah we're
talking to Kirk Herbstreit from the
mothership called the game last night
with Chris Fowler by the way the
overnight rating is 16.7 that's up 9%
from from last year you brought up a
point where I thought it was really
interesting but it was very sneaky what
you said that you thought that Sabin had
up tempo almost to keep to a from not
being able to think too much so he had
to just sort of react and not sit there
and think as you have a freshman in the
biggest game of his life
I thought it was it was a great point
but it was just a you know like oh by
the way threw this out there and then
back to the game action so I thought it
was great point yeah that in all sports
sometimes when you have a young player
on especially on that big of a stage the
quicker you can go and the more
instinctive he can be or he doesn't have
to sit there and think about oh my gosh
you know this is a big play I think it
kind of gives them into a rhythm and
gets them to kind of forget about some
of the distractions and I thought that
they really sensed when to put their
foot on the accelerator and when to pull
back and after that that scramble that
first drive he just seemed to kind of
settle and I thought that maybe the
biggest play of the game
remember when he rolled left and for
whatever reason maybe we'll find out
later all of his receivers and the tight
end or blocking they're there they're 12
yards downfield blocking and it was the
only time he really showed his use he's
rolling left and he just kind of no
one's looking imagine the receivers
everybody has it back to you and they're
blocking and he just kind of forced it
in there and tried to hope that somebody
might turn around eventually and catch
the ball and instead Georgia gets a big
interception and you're thinking oh my
gosh and the shot that we had of him
coming over who in the world does this
to Nick Saban he's a freshman it about
his personality he comes over he's got
his arm around Nick Saban's back and
he's like you'd almost feel better coach
that one's on my bad I'll get it back my
back it was just like most guys they run
to the other end of the team's box and
it's like maybe he won't see me over
here he comes right over and have a
smile on us any man coach that was on me
you know and and sure enough they come
back they hit another big play and about
the touchdown pass to Ridley where he
scrambles left last-second delivers the
ball just so many big plays that you
know we'll go back and look at it how
did this one happen and how did that one
happen it was incredible hey Herbie pass
along to Chris I was a it was a lot of
fun
I love the Rose Bowl as well and you
know hopefully get a little bit of
downtime thanks for joining us yeah hey
thanks a lot Dan look forward to
watching you this rest of the post thank
you buddy that's a Kirk Herbstreit from
the mothership for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]